you
before the German enters the chamber I
just read out the emergency evacuation
announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building via the nearest available exit
to the chamber our assembly points will
be in the public car park at the side of
this Civic suite please do not delay
your evacuation to collect any
belongings please do not return to the
building until given permission to do so
by council staff please note that this
meeting is being audio recorded may also
reminded everyone to switch off their
mobile phones or put them on their
silent thank you would you now please be
upstanding to receive the Chairman the
Chairman's chaplain and the managing
director
[Music]
good evening everybody
prayers from my chaplain chaplain mr.
Richard Isles evening everyone
brief story Jack and Max were walking
away from church and Jack wonders
whether it would be all right to dance
while praying and Max replies I don't
know why don't you go and ask the vicar
say Jack go ask the vicar and says
father would it be all right to dance
while I pray for the bigger replies no
my sons
no my son you may not it is
disrespectful so his friend Max and says
you take that and Max said I'm not
surprised you asked the wrong question
let me try
so max goalies and says to the liquor
fella may I pray why does to which the
priest legally replies and says by all
means by all men and immoral
you ace it I would like to welcome the
members of the public who are here it's
very very nice to see so many at one of
our meetings I would just like to just
confirm with you that this is a council
meeting and unfortunately you aren't
allowed to ask any questions but I'm
sure there will be lots of things that
you will find interesting and find
useful in this presentation so thank you
very much for coming
so item number one apologies for absence
okay
councillor Burton councillor Dre
counselor mrs. Mason counselor mr. Mason
councillor Ino and council mrs. Rowe
yeah I was just going to say if the
apologies for councillor wrote
ironically she's had to attend the
walking Center it's at the hospital we
send her our best wishes Kathleen the
chairman council Toby Mountain has
city's authorities to be hopes to get
here he is running late Thank You
councillor black and you thank you
that's that's right
right okay thank you very much any other
apologies all right item number three
sorry number two
compound cap now country to receive
declarations of interest counselor
couple Thank You children I'm a member
of the Essex health and well-being board
representing the southern districts of
the county I chair the local health and
well-being board four kalsa point and
Rochford and I'm also a governor at
Southland Hospital on behalf of Essex
County Council thank you hmm councillor
Webb thank you madam chairman I also sit
on the board of governors at Southend
University Hospitals Trust and my wife
works as a doctor in Broomfield Hospital
any others okay thank you very much all
right item number three is the
presentation it's the future of Health
and Care Services in the Rochford
district and we have representatives
from the Health Service to do a
presentation and thank you very much for
coming along tonight and I think dr.
Ronan Swinton's sorry and then dr. Ellen
Clinton is going to leave the
presentation yes Thank You chair yes sir
thank you for inviting us to present to
you tonight
we are really anxious to do so and
welcome the opportunity and welcome the
fact that the meeting is in public and
are very pleased to so many to see so
many of the public here this is an issue
that affects everybody and we want to
hear from everybody regarding their
views I'm going to hopefully speak very
briefly initially and hand over to my
colleague Ian Stinson and where I to be
a member of the public I would be
worried about press reports and I just
would wish to assure people
of the facts on this slide there are no
plans to close an A&E at any of the
three hospitals and in all the options
being discussed it will continue to be
in A&E that at each Hospital and we will
discuss what that may or may not mean
later on and we have no firm endpoints
at present and we will discuss what we
mean by that later on and it's really
important that this is about the entire
healthcare delivery in our region of 1.2
million people and that clinic
clinicians are actively involved in
leading the development I hope you will
feel that is the case and on matters
that are requiring public consultation
there will be public consultation I
thought I should say that right from the
outset because I can imagine that there
is disquiet out there about those issues
and I thought I just threw up straight
before my colleague Ian Stetson moves on
with the presentation and starts to tell
you what our thoughts are currently
about the primary care and community
changes that may occur in our region so
at hand straight over Dylan thank you
Ron
so I'm entered it's the nominee
accountable officer for cost point and
Rochford Clinical Commissioning group
and I'd like to just take you through
briefly some of the work and some of our
thinking in terms of what is going to be
happening in the community for
healthcare for the provision of patients
and residents in our locality and just
to pick up on on that point that ronan
said what we are doing now is as a
system working together to transform
services for our patients and there's
been a lot of discussion about what it
means for the acute hospital and that's
right and how acute hospitals will need
to change into the future but in tandem
to that is the need to ask the question
how do we then change and transform the
not in hospital services the primary
care services that you all will be
receiving you're already
stupid general practice in our locality
how does that need to change as we go
forward to deliver a more effective and
seamless service to you that is joined
up with the services provided at the
interface between community and acute so
why change why do we need to change and
everyone automatically says well it's
all about the money I mean money is
important yes but actually it's about
what is happening in our communities and
what's happening to our population and
we know that there is an increasing
demand on our population from our
population in terms of health and care
services 81% of GPS report they are
actually seeing patients with more
complex conditions those such as
diabetes COPD dementia asthma are more
more people are busying are being seen
and that's because our population is
getting older and living longer and
that's partly because we're able to
intervene and provide more intensive and
appropriate services at an earlier stage
so we can keep people healthier for a
longer period of time but actually
because we're doing that our GPS our
primary care provision are seeing more
and more people on a yearly basis if you
link that to the rise in a and E we have
seen particularly in our locality a real
hike up in the number of people using
our A&E services and the figures there
are quite stark where you see our
numbers and how they've risen against
the national average which is 1.6
percent but we hear in mid and South
Essex have seen a four point six
increase in activity and that is a
significant pressure again on services
and something that we will need to
address and to find a different way of
how we can deliver services for the
population we know that as we look
forward that the demographics of our
population are going to continue
new to get older we're going to have
more over 85 year olds and we've ever
had before in our community in the next
10-15 years and we need to be able to
shape our services now to be fit for the
future and be sustainable to deliver
services as we go forward the other
thing that we are acutely conscious of
as we've gone through this process and
are going through this process is that
we are still too fragmented and if I
take the out of out of hospital services
that we provide the general practice the
community services district nurses
pharmacists dentists they're not tied up
they're not linked up and the service
provision is still has gaps in between
and from a patient's perspective your
pathway of care does not always follow
in a seamless way and that's the thing
we have to address and we also have to
address how then that then works into
the hospital in a seamless way and again
out of the hospital back into the
community so that's that's a key
component of what we are here to do we
know that our traditional workforce is
not sustainable
our current GP workforce are getting
older like the population and they're
already extremely stretched our
clinicians are there's a huge
demographic of particularly with GPS
from our perspective that are reaching
you know 60 65 and we know that in
southeast but also in the rest of Essex
and much wider across the country the
GPS are finding it increasingly
difficult to secure new GPS within their
practice and I'm sure with you you're
all registered with practices many of
you will probably have picked up that as
a GP leaves a long-standing partner it's
not an automatic replacement and GPS
finding it more and more difficult to to
recruit and hold on to GPS for the
future we know that modern standards are
being
require for hospital specialists we know
that services are needing to be
delivered over those 24/7 seven days a
week and how we would do that that again
adds pressure and as I said there is a
huge recruitment pressure in our system
it's GPS yes but there's also issues
around recruiting nurses there's the
change in terms of training for nurses
that will probably feed into the system
going forward so we know that if we
relied on recruitment and and said to
our system will actually just keep going
keep putting the adverts out that we
would come to a halt we have to find new
ways of working new teams of delivering
services that are different but too deep
and and resilient to those changes so
what is it that you have said and and
this is quite a useful slider thing
because through the process of
engagement that we've been having with
our public in mid and South Essex we've
asked you what are the things that
actually need to improve across our
system and if you look at those top 12
where you start with and it's often when
I go to meetings the first thing people
ask me is about access and access
particularly to general practice that
does appear at the top there so this is
about how can we improve that access how
can we have a consistent service for our
population through general practice and
that links again to community care as
well to our district nurses to our
health visitors and and and the range of
provision that we have across there
prevention is also extremely poor and
important and when I say prevention I
also mean self-care and self-care really
starting bus start to play an important
role in how we deliver our services
because the longer we can keep people
healthier and the more engaged we can be
with those individuals in terms of their
own
so we can delay and and eliminate those
unnecessary
activity in the Community Services and
into the hospital so looking down those
top 12 probably you won't come down to
the hospital experience until near the
end and that's really interesting
because I think a lot of our debate and
discussion today has been around the
hospital but actually what matters for
the people that we've engaged with is
much around social care within the
community so this is the overall plan
and it's it's three bubbles and if you
look in the bottom left-hand corner what
I'm talking about here is actually
looking to transform and change how your
local services are delivered how your GP
practice will change and how it delivers
that service how they will intervene
differently how they will work in a
joined up way and by doing that they
will ensure that the top of our table
will allow people to live well and live
longer well and be able to have their
own plans be confident in terms of what
they need have the treatment
intervention at an earlier stage and if
we get that right then we unblock the
blockages that are currently in the
hospital so we take a proportion of
people out of the system by intervening
an earlier stage for their local
services and enabling them to live well
they won't need to go to hospital they
won't need to be at A&E or through
non-elective
activity elective activity and by
allowing that to happen the hospital
then frees up resources that can then go
back into primary care and be reinvested
to really develop and strengthen our
interventions that we can do in
in the community so it's a circle and
we're all in it together in hospital and
out of hospital and we can't do this on
our own so this diagram shows us the way
we can do that
give you a little flavor of how we are
beginning to change primary care and out
of hospital services in your locality
and this is from a closer point than
Rogers perspective but these type of
things are happening throughout the
breadth of of mid and South ethics but
we have now commissioned a local service
for the population that is offering GP
plan GPS appointment at weekends and in
the last year we have delivered over
8,000 additional appointments to
patients that were not in the system the
previous year but not only that we've
done it in a way where we brought
together practices to agree to say well
actually we will all sign up to
directing our patients if they wish to
have that service so as with 25
practices we have 20 practices signed up
to this service and we are planning to
move to the full 25 by the end of the
year we have another element to take
into account is if the progress we've
made is that we have divided our CCG
into four localities
what should really cost point can be
island and been fleet and we have got
GPS in those localities working together
and saying how can we change services
for our population what can we do and
how can we work together to deliver a
more effective service so we have now
got those practices sitting around the
table and saying actually let's start to
change our workforce let's start to
bring in new resources new people to
actually take some of the burden off the
GPS and allow the GPS to spend more time
with those more complex patients so we
now have pharmacists that are employed
across a locality that are working for
those GPS we have emergency care
practitioners the first one of those
started probably about four months ago
in them fleet that is now working across
all those practices in been fleet we
have advanced nurse practitioner this
the first
one that we've got its got the
specialism in long-term conditions and
again is working across a series of
practices we've also implemented what we
call are calling care coordination and
this is a service where all our
practices have identified the most
complex and vulnerable of their patients
and we have commissioned a completely
new service that is nervs lead but
actually involves Social Care and the
voluntary sector to take those
individuals and to wrap a care plan
around them in to intervene and give
them a point of contact so that if they
do become vulnerable and if they do have
a need they have someone to contact and
the range of services that can be
delivered for for them that service has
been in place now for over a year we
have 1700 patients on that service that
are linked in with the service and are
making a real difference to their life
and maintaining their health for longer
and actually doing one thing that we've
never done before
and that is make the joining up and we
came to about the fragmented system
joining up how we work between health
and social care and that is a really
essential piece of work that we're doing
we've also recognized that we had a a
pattern of provision across care homes
that was a bit mixed up really so you
know one care home could have about
three or four different practices linked
into it delivering slightly different
services so in railey we now have in our
care homes a dedicated practice that is
delivering a service for those care
homes and they've been commissioned to
deliver services not your core general
practice services but a service that is
designed to intervene and to look at the
needs again of some of our most
vulnerable patients to ensure that those
services those patients have timely
intervention and quick intervention and
by doing that
we're avoiding the need for those
individuals to turn up at the hospital
for for interventions that could have
been avoided we're also looking an umber
of different schemes across the county
across the CCG around how we use how we
we improve access for patients telephone
consultations a consultation the use of
text for population one of the biggest
challenges when we look at the services
we provide is the number of patients
that do not turn up for appointments it
can be as much as 25% in some areas and
some general practice so you actually
have general practice sitting there not
as seeing patients because those
patients haven't turned up through the
use of technology we are just piloting
at this moment in time a system that
will remind a patient that their
appointment is happening the next day
but also allowing the patient to cancel
the appointment directly on the back of
the text and as a result of that it's
freeing up a number of appointments in
that practice and that means that
practice is able to see more patients on
that day I just leave you with the one
of one of the latest headlines that it's
happening in our area in orderly meals
over in Raley it's big practice about
ten partners they've taken quite a brave
step in terms of transformation they
said well actually we're going to change
our system so that everyone who phones
up will get a triage from a doctor on
the line on the day they call and if
through that triage process we decide
actually the patient does need to click
up to come in to see us
we will see that patient on the day in
our practice so it's only been going a
week but we have seen the amount of
contacts go up from 1,000 to 2,000 you
might think how on earth can that
I just cope with that because of the
efficiency of how the system is working
the actual by the end of the week the
GPAs are saying actually it's freed up
more time for me so even though I've had
contact with more patients I've been
able to do more because of the way the
system works so we're going to be
watching that with great interest to see
how that sore the beds down in our
community listening to patients
experience etc cetera but I think I'd
leave it there because these are the
type of things that we will be doing to
transform how services are delivered for
you as patients in your locality it will
be based around no cavities it will be
based on GPS working together
effectively with social care with the
voluntary sector and with a wider and
deeper workforce in general practice so
I think that summarizes where we are
going with health and care and I think I
now hand over to Ronan again thank you
in so just just working the technology
here and thanks very much and we see the
slide again describing sort of in a very
broad brush picture what is proposed and
I think it's really important to realize
that the majority of our impact as
patients with the Health Service is not
in hospital and that is why on that
those twelve points that the hospital
came down number twelve but the work
that Ian and colleagues are doing in the
what we call the out of hospital did is
actually crucial to how you and I will
receive healthcare in the future Carolyn
and I both work in hospitals and to us
that's our life and I'm here to tell you
about what our thoughts has been over
the last but year and a half as we've
worked with many many people to try and
think of how we might alter and improve
our Hospital services for the future and
in broad terms the bottom right hand
corner does give a little taste that we
do feel it's important to try and
separate emergency sir emergency care
from planned care to recognize that some
specialist emergency treatments are
better delivered in specialist centers
and to streamline specialist care and
but overall let's just see what we did
at the very beginning we said you know
looking at what we have because we don't
have a blank sheet of paper what
actually are we able to move around and
we came to a conclusion very early on
that there were a few things we called
them Givens but for example if you go to
Southend right now there are the
fantastic radiotherapy and cancer
service there the radiotherapy Sweden if
you knew about building radiotherapy
Suites you'd realize that's a pretty
major piece of kit it would be pointless
jacking that up on wheels and moving it
to Bloomfield or Basildon similarly
we've got a cardiothoracic Center in
Basildon and apart from the building
itself the teamwork that has developed
there and the systems that have
developed there we recognized there was
no point in moving that and we also felt
the same for the tertiary referral
service that exists at Bloomfield for
burns and plastic surgery so at the very
beginning we kind of thought that they
were things that would remain and that
decision actually does impact on what
else wraps around them because I'm that
kind of an important thing to remember
that's what we did right at the
beginning for those reasons we did feel
that at all sites there should be
24-hour any and we'll discuss what that
means involved we didn't feel that as
well as that and it was interesting to
hear a colleague mentioned that someone
has gone to an assessment center we feel
that at each of the three sites there
should be what are called medical and
surgical assessment units frailty
assessment units because that is a huge
factor of our health care need at
present the the elderly and the frail
and we will all be in that number
hopefully one day but we need specialist
attention and we we think a unit such as
that should be available at all three
sites a children's assessment unit at
all three sites for management of the
initial presentation of ill children all
sites to continue to have outpatient
clinics day surgery maternity as they do
now and they would need if we move
things around and reconfigure they would
need to be able to repatriate patients
who have perhaps gone to other sites for
their specialist treatment that's what
we thought around initially what does
that actually mean and actually it means
not a lot of change for the majority of
things that people currently go to
hospital for in most of our our modeling
it kind of means about a five percent
change and I say that not to lull you
into a false sense of security so you
can say well it's okay nothing is going
to change but just to give you an idea
of the scale because we feel something
has to change and if you know if I put
everybody to sleep in this room and I
could actually right now and you woke up
five years later what we would hope is
that you would say and you had to enjoy
this different then it was five years
ago and more importantly this is better
than it was five years ago and I don't
want to go back five years that's the
aim of large-scale change that we're
after so even though from a hospital
perspective I put it at five percent and
that
still impacts quite a lot on the care
delivered now we we spent a lot of time
over a year and a half discussing what
potentially this would mean for our
three hospitals in terms of their
configuration what would go where and
one of the key questions was how would
specialized services be delivered by the
three hospitals and we came up with a
concept of the possibility of three
different types of hospitals delivering
specialist care in three different
manners one will be a hospital that
really focused on emergency care
specialized emergency care for the
sickest people who needed there and then
that would be the job of one hospital
and that was in line with national
guidance and we you will see a slide in
a minute that shows that outline as a
red hospital and we just use the color
red to help us discuss it and you will
see that shortly
we felt that another type of hospital
would be one that would balance that as
well as elective an elective care means
plan care it means me being told run on
your going to hospital next week to have
a new hip that's a planned event so that
hospital would be able to do emergency
care as per the red hospital but also
the planned and then we had the concept
of a yellow hospital and that would be
one that would focus mainly on the
planned care because one of the things
we are very aware of is that the planned
care because of the load on the
emergency care gets pushed aside
continually which for the individual
patient is a dreadful patient experience
you come in and they say Ron I'm sorry
we can't do your operation today because
there is no bed and you say well I
understand perfectly I know that the
Nadeau patient in there but still it
impacts on you your life your family
everything and impacts on the economic
use of the resource because that theater
is either doing that that's a resource
that you and I are paying for at that
time and the concept of the yellow
hospital is one that that could be
spared from the impact
of the emergency load so that it could
focus on providing the care for the
elective patients less canceled
operations more efficient use of
resource and it rolls on now when you
consider those three types of hospitals
and you try and distribute them in
various ways around the three hospitals
that we have you get a diagram such as
this and you can see that for the three
hospitals we have we said well what is
puzzled and was red blue field was
orange and actually we didn't have
yellow in Southend orange and and at the
very bottom you see what is better than
was orange Broomfield was red in
southern was yellow and those are the
permutations and combinations of those
three concepts in our in our area we
actually went a step further with this
and we said you know what there are a
lot of permutations and combinations
there this is large scale change if
there was to be a preference what would
it be and we convened an appraisals
option process with external
stakeholders with local clinicians with
patient representatives a quite a
thorough process and actually from that
process they said if you were to focus
on any two because it might be easier to
do so they would suggest focusing
primarily on 2a which has Basildon of
the red-green field of the orange south
end of the yellow are from the 1a which
has no yellow the one section which is
no yellow focusing on 1a which is
dazzling as a bedroom field and south
end as the orange that was what came
from that appraisals option process now
that's where we are on this concept
right now and that's the work of hours
of meetings hours of groups getting
together and discussing what actually is
possible and it really and many many
clinicians actively involved in the
process and it's really important
to listen to what I've just said many
many clinicians actively involved and
it's also important for you to know and
to appreciate that it doesn't mean that
all clinicians are totally comfortable
with this this is big change any of
these represent big change and it is a
not surprising be appropriate and see
comforting that actually within the
clinical body and in many respects Carol
and I Caroline and I represent probably
I don't represent what we stand up as a
bunch of I'm about nine hundred
consultants probably five thousand
nurses that's the clinical body that
you're talking about and some of them
like some of you are not comfortable
teas and that's good because what that
does is it pushes us to reevaluate and
take it bit by bit as we move it forward
and rather than feel frightened by that
I want you to feel comforted by that
fact what does it mean in my view from
an A&E perspective because I think
that's the question people want to know
yeah to me any of these permutations and
combinations would mean that all three
areas would have an A&E that those A&E s
would be capable of dealing with the
presentation the emergency presentation
of any
that as right now with any illness they
would be capable of dealing with the
emergency presentation stabilizing them
and then trying and sending that patient
on to foil it is necessary to send them
be that home or into the hospital as
happens now in all our hospitals are as
also happens now by the way on for many
occasions actually you know what this
patient would better be treated in
another one of our hospitals when that
happens right now for many conditions
and and and obviously all of that
depends on close working with primary
care close working with the East of
England ambulance service and a
transport point of view but that's how I
see it and I think it's important to
know that not everybody sees it like
that and so and I know my colleague
Caroline doesn't and so I think it's
right that you hear caroline express her
views on this so I think as Ronan has
said we certainly be working for about
18 months as part of the success regime
with with various meetings and that has
involved both myself as a lead clinician
in Southend any meeting with the leak
missions based at Broomfield and at
battled in' and with a lot of other
members of staff as well as with our
lead nurses and managers my concerns
arise really because from my point of
view and I can say I do have I'm here
representing both of the lead conditions
and Broomfield and Basildon as well that
we do not agree with what has been put
forward on the options appraisal we are
categorically stated we did not agree
with the development of specialists or
red Hospital for accident and emergency
and that was after working through those
meetings for a number of months and
there's a number of reasons behind that
we don't feel it addresses many of the
issues that that should be addressed
would hopefully be addressed and in
honesty there are not some solutions to
those that are available at this moment
in time either we say
from our point of view heard about
complex elderly and frailty needs and
really from our point of view that is
what is a second how emergency
departments function at this moment in
time so the problem that we have
function is an emergency department is
that once we've seen a patient and we
want to admit them there is nowhere in
the hospital for them to go to looking
at all of this and whether we have red
orange yellow whatever type of hospitals
we have the bottom line still exists
that we don't have enough medical
frailty beds on any of the sites they
will always be overspill into what's
your elected areas so without the
community coming up from first and
dealing with that ever-growing
population we don't see it solving
actually the crux of the matter and the
crux of the matter is not how the
emergency departments are functioning
it's about how we prevent elderly people
coming into hospital how we in effect
turn them around quickly so they are in
hospital for a long time and how we stop
them coming back again because that's a
major problem and we don't feel that
this arts as any of those problems there
are definitely problems from an any
point of view you've had staffing they
mentioned we are concerned that this is
stated to address the staffing when we
look at what staffing you need to staff
a red norwich in a yellow hospital you
actually end up needing more staff you
end up needing more ane consultants
because the intensity of such what would
happen at battled in hospital you
actually do need 24/7 consultant cover
there as well as we'd be until we've got
24/7 ATS on both the other two sites
again we are shuttling numbers between
three sites we aren't increasing that in
any way the definition of a 24/7 A&E has
also been a concern of s so if you look
at the various orange and yellow
Hospital options they would involve
ambulances bypassing that Hospital even
in totality or in certain hours of the
day as an a lead Akhter who went into
any because I love it and because I
actually want to see acutely ill people
I would not work at yella Hospital
because it doesn't bring me what ur need
na very any consultant would work
- yellow Hospital that's not what
they've trained for that's not what they
want to see so to say that there will be
a 24/7 A&E on each side I think is a
misnomer and again from from the success
regime meetings we felt that actually we
should be honest here and we should be
saying that that will result in a
downgrade to a walk-in Center if it
doesn't we actually feel that will be
more dangerous at the moment if someone
walks in and we do have a high number of
walk-ins with serious medical ecology
out there then we are able to manage
them recognize and treat them because
that's what we do with the 70 to 100
ambulances that we have a day coming
anyway if we don't have those 72 one and
100mbs is coming a day we are not going
to use to recognizing treating and
managing patients with serious pathology
they are going to have a worse outcome
they're not going to do as well so we
actually cells as a group that you could
not call this an A&E you should not call
this an A&E and you should call it
walking centre the concern and from our
point of view calling this a specialist
E&E a red centre is that there are
groups of patients that do better by
going to specialist units absolutely
hands up the evidence is out there
however that's already happened and
quite happy was talking detail I don't
want to get into medical jargon but
there are groups of patients that do
better by going to a specialist centre
some of those are you areare able to
identify them pre-hospital II so you'll
hear that patient with a heart attack
already go to babble Dhin the truth is
that's a small percentage of patients
that have a heart attack that equates to
about two patients per week have a
diagnostic ECG which the paramedics can
do and then they can take them direct to
the cardiothoracic centre of note they
do not go to Basildon A&E they go to the
cardiothoracic centre that pathway is
already in place the same exists for
other conditions because we know that so
actually for better outcomes the
evidence is there the changes already be
made that's all or all in action the
concern from a clinical point of view is
actually the evidence shows that long as
you travel the more likely you are to
die and for every 10 kilometers you
travel the best UK evidence shows you
have a 1% higher risk of dying and if
you have a respiratory problem which
southend again
a very high respiratory illness rate and
we've already mentioned the COPD and as
most complex problems that's 2% so the
my concern is as a clinician I'm told to
do the best by my patients this is not
the best by my patient now the good side
is absolutely we need to be working
together
there are definitely positive to be had
here there's definitely improvements to
be made here but my concern is is that
we haven't been listened to we have come
up with alternatives which we feel
better for patients and we're very
concerned that the five options left on
the options appraisal are not what we
have supported thanks Arlen thanks
Carolyn and you're probably really
surprised to hear that and I'm really
glad caroline has broken because what
you see in front of you are two people
who are passionate about making things
better both of us are passionate what
isn't at issue here is who rice because
actually I might be wrong
Caroline might be wrong but one thing
you can be assured of is this we are
people both of us who want to do it
right and we intend to work together and
do it step by step
bit by bit not turn on anything if it
doesn't make sense to do so and if on
testing it doesn't work because actually
I believe in this I really do
Caroline and some of her colleagues
don't and that's what you've heard and
we've been very honest here tonight and
it's really important to be so and
rather than going out the door
frightened I would suggest you go out
the door think it's good to see two
professionals who are willing to stand
up and give two different views and work
together because that's what we'll do
and we will do it step by step we will
actually take a phased approach
to any changing where we will get to at
the end of this process I actually don't
know I think personally that it will be
very good to get to one of those in fact
end results but that's just me caroline
has a view which is very valid and we
may end up somewhere in between but one
thing I guarantee you we will be working
together and we will be making sure
whatever we do ends up the best for
patients because that's what we do and
it is not a surprise that there is
disagreement amongst professionals on
this this is big stuff this is hard
stuff and anybody involved in
large-scale change will and I'm sure as
counselors you yourself have been
involved in many types of change and
rarely had the luxury of a unanimous
agreement amongst you and may have come
to a better agreement because of that
and that's what I hope will come out of
this so I'll hand on to Tom now who will
take you through some more
[Music]
Sorokin
okay fine Christ so I'm telling I'm one
of the executive directors now
responsible for Southend as Odin and
Broomfield hospitals and I think from
the the board of the three organizations
we're absolutely committed to getting
this right and one of the things that we
recognize that we need to do and the
conversation that we've had
just-just-just now around some of the
issues and concerns around our current
proposals is that we need to listen and
we need to listen not only to our
clinicians but we also need to listen to
our communities and their concerns and
worries and issues and we are absolutely
committed to doing that over the course
of this summer and this is this is one
of many opportunities that we have to
hear your views and your concerns and to
help us inform our ideas so given where
we're currently at given the concerns
that there currently are and the work
that clearly needs to be done and to
work through it a more detailed level
what our end proposals will be within
any sort of public consultation we're
doing two things so the first thing is
continuing to work with Ian and the
other colleagues across the other
commissioning groups across MIT and
South Essex to really help them
accelerate some of these developments
outside of the hospital because we know
that actually the key in terms of
getting our hospitals and so they're
delivering kind of safe and effective
services all of the time as Caroline
said is by beginning to manage frail
older people better the second is the
work that we need to do in the hospital
and that work is around us beginning to
better articulate what are our proposals
on an individual condition specific
level
and so what we're doing we set up a
clinical reference group made up of
senior clinicians from the three
organizations which is shortly going to
be meeting and then we've also are
initiating four groups to work through
what we describes blueprints and what I
mean by blueprints are ones when you
turn up at any Hospital and what changes
might there be which would deliver a
benefit to patients that we would then
consult on and those those four groups
are a group focusing on our kind of
emergency care and the functionality of
each of the A&E departments of three
hospitals the second is around how do we
address some of the issues that caroline
has just described around our core
general medicine and surgical emergency
admissions the third is are there any
things that we can do around better
separating some of our planned care so
we are not in a position where we are
cancelling as many patients as roans
describes and the final area is around
pediatrics and so that's work that we
need to do and that work will be led by
senior clinicians from across the three
hospitals working it through on a
patient condition by patient condition
level so given that we in terms of the
timescales around when things will
happen
and when we will get to the point where
we've got some final proposals we've got
some time so we are continuing the local
discussions that we've had to date and
will continue to have with our local
communities and with our clinicians and
that will run through to September this
year we currently anticipate we then
have to complete something called a pre
consultation business case because we
have to go through a national assurance
process on any proposals that we make
them which goes through NHS England
which is one of our regulators
we then have to go through that surance
process and that will also include
working with the three local authorities
scrutiny committees and then we would
then initiate a consultation program and
so at the moment we think the formal
public consultation activity would start
in December of this year and run through
to March 2018
there'll be analysis obviously of all of
the feedback that we've had on our
proposals from local people and we would
refine that refine those proposals based
on that feedback and so we currently
anticipate that the decision would be
made in May 2018 so that that's our
current time frame and so what I want to
assure you from this is we're not we're
not going to rush this we need to get it
right and we need to make sure that
we've had enough time to work through
the proposals in the right level of
detail so that both our clinical teams
are comfortable with whatever it is that
we proposed but equally also you and the
communities of MIT and South Essex are
comfortable with what we proposed so
that I think that's everything that we
were going to talk and I think we are
happy to open up to questions yeah like
to say thank you that was quite a good
presentation I'm sure we've got lots of
questions or I would hear we've got
questions what I what I was done set
this stage can we have one question from
each of you so that to start with so
that I can then go around and everybody
gets a chance to speak but it doesn't
mean to say I'm not going to come back
to you
please condense the cutoff
since these these things don't work
unless you turn the other one off
unfortunately thank you for the
presentation I can't say I'm terribly
reassured by what I've seen because you
haven't really made any decisions yet or
at least the decisions that you seem to
be wanting to make do cause problems I
think for local people and clearly local
people particularly in Rockland where
you close those people really have real
concerns about how we're going to carry
forward one of the things and I'll just
ask one question if I may because I'm
sure there are other questions that will
come forward but this actually came from
a member of parliament because as far as
transporting people around its concerned
there is a lack of ambulance from the
eastern engine eastern england ambulance
already now if we are involving
ambulances in longer journeys can you
assure us that part of the equation is
to actually increase the ambulance
service and to take on the right people
with the right skills to actually staff
those entrances
yes that they we couldn't possibly do
this without involving assuming
remembrance they are involved in the
process the issue that you bring up are
exactly the issues that they speak to us
about there would be no point in
suggesting that we could do this without
them upscaling changing how they operate
so they are part of the process it's not
a simple equation but we wouldn't
operationalize that any of what but I
have outlined without that being very
much part of the equation capsule good
insane
Thank You chair on the ice is November
earrings Ditton than the presentation to
the counselors where I raised concerns
about the the agency staffing which is
obviously costing far more to taxpayers
and I was advised that there will be
staffing coming in from Spain and the
Philippines to bridge this gap are you
able to confirm doctor held that this
has happened I'm not not certain what
particular specialties they will be
talking about whether it was accident
and emergency there are that part of
nationwide there are shortages in IES
unfortunately it's not a popular
specialty to work in and the latest
thing as I had was from a Royal College
that she sort of manages every a knee in
the country that two years ago 50% of
all consultant or senior registrar faces
agent in the UK and that's the situation
we were looking at at Southend actually
we are one of the best staff departments
of senior registrar's in the country at
all from a nursing point of view there
have been some nursing recruitment from
the EU from the Philippines I would
still say that staffing is probably the
number one problem for all three
hospitals probably I can't speak for all
of them but probably most hospitals in
the UK from from a Broomfield
perspective which is is the hospital I
probably know best I know that we have
increased our nursing staff over the
last five years quite substantially
actually and managed that through
international recruitment at times and
much of that has been driven by
increased standards and requirement for
more nurses but there is constantly a
flux and there is constantly we would
never be at full establishment
that's not uncommon interesting yes
so so I just to feedback to you because
obviously this is this cuts across all
our organizations and the hospital has
just given an explanation about what's
happening from the hospital size from a
primary care side we also have an
initiative to attract 50 GPS from the EU
into mid and South Essex that
recruitment process has started and I'm
pleased to say that we have already
established eight GPS are being placed
within general practice within mid and
South Essex so we are beginning to get
more GPS from that route now that isn't
the answer because obviously we've got
to we've got to change how general
practice works and we've got to attract
the GPS we have got in this country into
southeast Essex but we believe that by
taking this fresh approach in terms of
how we deliver primary care we will
attract GPS into this area so it is not
the solution but it helps in terms of
our short-term planning to ensure we
deliver effective and fast treatment for
for you in primary care counselor mr.
high place preclinical inspectors and
I've always wondered what happens I
stand protective England productive
month or now now I think I would guess
what inclination bigos to one that I
believe this expresses the same concerns
that I've had
which I actually is why you are
protective period and I think doctor how
would probably with what she's said
today leading companies all of the
concerns that I've had but perhaps
introduced a few more I do have a lot of
questions dropping everyone he'll says
that hopefully other people will pick up
other questions I just wondered on I
think I'm not the presentation I'm very
happy with I agree with things with the
system said and I believe that the way
forward and I think that a lot of
concerns around what calleb said and I
and I find if we don't go the routes
that dr. Fenton is suggested with ima
how you would dr. houses in what the
infinities to say as we are obviously
slightly different a lot of what that
includes thank you well as I said I've
been involved in probably 18 months now
with and since the success regime was
announced and that has meant that we are
working closer together across the three
sites which i think is a good thing
the kind of model that that the freaking
the free clinically to the sites are
looking at is what we will call a treat
and transfer model so each ami would
continue to receive the patients that
they receive now those that we do send
off elsewhere such as that the till we
contacted the cardiothoracic center
would still go there we would then treat
and stabilize and diagnose those
patients and I think it is important I
have discussed directly with the eastern
ambulance service lead that was involved
in the success of you and I don't want
to appear derogatory to limit at all but
they are not able to diagnose these
patients and pick out the ones before
they get to hospital and and he was in
total agreement with me that with that
once we then had a diagnosis we would
then look at what patients would do
better either going to your specialist
unit or what patients it would make
sense from a service provision will go
to a specialist unit so a good example
of that was some patients will have a
gastrointestinal bleed of a bleed on the
gut the sort of the proposal of
transferring them many miles well they
can't be stabilized essentially you know
they need certain drugs they need a
blood transfusion they need talking back
to debt cetera so to propose to
transcend them further would result in a
higher mortality if they would go to
their local anywhere they go now they
would receive all that and be stabilized
now at the moment and all three Hospital
sites there is a GI bleed on call rota
now I think anecdotally and I don't have
the figures for it hands up but
anecdotally probably two patients a
month itself they
go for an emergency GI procedure
overnight now that doesn't make sense
therefore to have three different honk
or rotors across the three sites what
would make sense is to have one one
place on call or even the possibility of
a mobile GI on core team that go to
where the patient is that would make
sense
from a lifestyle from a rotor point of
view manpower and for a safety for the
patient point of view so that is the
proposal that asses and lead clinicians
were put in we would work out what
patients really needed that specialist
emergency input and how that would
happen and it is worth saying that
that's exactly our first step well as
they indicated because of the you know
did the clinical worry that does exist
we are taking this in a step-by-step
approach and to see how this model would
work out would be our first step because
it would be an improvement on what we
have at present whether it actually will
create the difference we need is another
question but it's an example of us
listening and working together so the
worry you have which I understand you
know phrase for two people but I'd like
to reassure you that we are actually
working it and as professionals we can
disagree we can also come together
Council would
Thank You chairman so I I am one if you
can hear me I you know it's kind of
worrying at times but I was interested
in in the points that both dr. hound and
dr. Fenton have made the collateral
damage concept and where that's being
modeled in that you're bringing up where
if you've got distances to travel that
is extremely worrying and I wonder if
that's been put into the modeling and
what is an acceptable percentage for
such collateral damage that might come
up but what my main question was going
to be on bed blocking which i think is a
major national issue and I've sort of
had personal experience of this with my
mother-in-law in Southend Hospital where
she was in there and they couldn't find
you know a place for her to go and and
this was extremely difficult going back
to a place in the care and one of the
things there seems to be a lot of
confusion between clinical and social
care whether you need that the clinical
help or whether you're going to get the
social help and this is that this seems
to be a big problem it causes anxiety I
wonder how much that's going to be
addressed and the point that you brought
up as well was with regard which I found
was interesting if someone is actually
going to either Broomfield only been
really on the leave in great Wakering
there was something in your mentality
which is saying that as long as soon as
they are on the recovery the road to
recovery you're gonna try and repatriate
them back for you know literally work
with recuperation to the nearest
hospital was that something that you
were trying to get across or or not I'm
just confused about that yep
so sort of two things the what way you
term instead barking would you which is
an unfortunate term because actually
these are patients who are in an
unfortunate position at the time and
you're absolutely right and as Caroline
stages that the actual flow through the
system is is the big problem and the the
ability and this is what Ian and his
colleagues are trying to address that's
why it has to be a whole system process
the ability to find appropriate social
care for patients who needed Andrea
Behrman is critical to achieving this
and at any one time I imagine in all of
our three hospitals that I would I don't
think it'd be far wrong in saying there
is an entire Ward with patients in it
who could be elsewhere and that it would
be beneficial and that's exactly what my
colleagues are trying to deal with with
respect to the transferring I mention it
because in some models it is the case
and I'm not suggesting it would be the
case but we have to consider it that the
initial acute treatment of a patient may
occur in one Center and this happens and
for example a trauma patient and this is
an extreme example who is treated in
edinburgh for example right now once
they are stabilized there they are
repatriated to one of our hospitals
that's one such mechanism and I my my
wish was just to point out that as a
pathway it exists and it may be a
pathway that we would want to employ I
think this is a great concern as well
from the repatriation point of view and
also for these frail elderly people the
possibility of taking them away from
their support network as well we know
for LDP why actually more so the
clinical director of Medicine now we
know for elderly people that if we do
transfer them just from ward toward that
that has detrimental effects on their
link to stay and also can cause a
deterioration particularly in those with
dementia because you're taking them from
somewhere very unfamiliar and now
putting them somewhere else very
unfamiliar and so the actual factors
then transferring them across hospital I
don't think it's the
fully accounted for and the effect that
will have on the overall length of stay
and therefore the bed blocking process
that you comment on as well my concern
would be that would increase even server
yeah
so just to cut to come back to you this
is a whole system thing we've got to
look at so you can't do one in the
isolation without the other and part of
the out of getting individuals out of
the hospital we have to look closely and
in a new different way in terms of how
health and social care work together to
ensure that we've got the right
placements in the right place as a range
of because people coming out with a
range of complexity but but you can't
look at this in isolation
there's the avoiding people going in
there's the treatment and the people
coming out and the one thing that we can
do across the success regime I'm sorry
the STP is ensure that we're we're
looking it together as a whole system
and find effective ways of reducing
instances like you've just given us I
appreciate that some people are wanting
to come back with second questions but
I've still got quite a long list of
those with their first questions so and
next time capsule hook why thank you
madam chairman I was just wondering how
the the experts here see what they're
looking to do in in regards to an
ever-increasing population and in
particular in this area which seems to
be rising quite significantly and how
that's going to affect your services and
if original your services going forward
if you're looking into the long term you
know in into five 10 years and you know
the population changes in that time
we're going to be quite significant and
on on that basis you mentioned that GP
services are quite crucial to how people
interact with the hospitals and there's
been mention that looking
you get GPS in from other areas and even
other countries but what are we doing as
South in University Hospital and other
other hospitals around the country to to
get our own GPS from our own populace
through the the system and into into
practice to replace the aging GPS are
looking to retire at some point I think
we need to really focus on providing
those sort of specialists from from our
own population and just one point about
local situation the drop-in center has
been closed and has been closed for this
one now I met a facility that I've
actually used myself and found it was
quite handy for me because of the
situation in my work made it difficult
for me to get an ordinary GPS
appointment now it would seem that at
that particular service is a service
that would have prevented some of the
impact on the A&E departments now surely
you should be looking to provide
services like that rather than take them
away thank you thank you for that so if
I just address the first thing around
attracting new GPS into the locality I
think there is quite an exciting
development that's happening at a are
you where there is a new medical school
being developed which will have links in
Essex so I think the that is a component
of actually bringing GPS into Essex and
keeping in Essex where we have training
practices and we bring individuals in to
be training to become GPS we know that
they stay in Essex a lot more than those
that are come in from the outside so I
think there is a there was a real
movement
Essex to train and develop general new
the new General Practitioners for the
future and we will we will we will tap
into that very strongly
I think part of this is around how we
change how we can change how a general
practice works because I think my
experience is when you go into general
practice and speech GPS they love their
job but they're just so overburdened
with the pressure and we've got to find
a way to take the pressure off of them
and change that primary care provision
and we are starting to do that and we
are starting to where we are bringing
more professionals working in general
practice working across genera practice
it is starting to free up the time if
you then and then take that step further
and actually say well actually how can
these group of practices then support
each other still retaining their own
identity and the services they deliver
and actually start to say well actually
you may have a GP that's got a special
ism in diabetes that has a team
associated with it that patients could
be seen there while still being seen or
under their own GP you're actually
taking pressure you're shifting how
services are delivered and you're making
general practice again an attractive
place to come to work and to stay so
you've got that level you've got the
level of training practices and you've
got obviously that wealth of people the
nurses but we can use more effectively
and more trained up to deliver more
services for poor general practice in
terms of simply asleep at was a Southend
CCG commissioned service clearly the the
decision was taken to to close and
Luke's down it didn't it didn't have the
impact on a A&E that some people were
concerned it did it was going to have
what in fact you were happening at some
Luke's was you have a number of activity
that we were pet we were paying for in
effect twice because individuals were
registering with another practice but
still using the same Luke's practice as
a walk-in not everyone so there was that
component that we needed at that time
for sad entities which you need to make
that decision but of course we all
looking at urgent care out of hospital
and that is perhaps a component that was
within some Luke's that can be then
looked at and fine-tuned to be delivered
more effectively for the locality and I
think there are lots of lessons we can
learn from that I mean it is done and
those walk-in centers across the length
and breadth of the country were closing
down I think they were originally set up
who remember for those that ran they
were called RC centers and every area
had I think there are components of that
service that could be refocused as we
start to reshape a service for a
locality that may look different for
those localities that are nearer
hospital to those that are
I would add that I think the mango
you're asking medical school will be a
real benefit to the Essex health
community and the problem from my point
of view is that the GP is coming out of
that that will be a ten year plan to get
through Medical School and then trained
as a GP so it's not going to be an
immediate answer my concern would remain
that for angular Africans a medical
school zone literature they will say
that we have the second highest number
of vacancies of GPS in the area and the
second highest number of GPS that are
due to retire in the next five years so
actually I think things are going to get
a lot worse before they can get better
and I think anything that's being
presented today and anything that
happens requires that community sorting
if you like beforehand because at the
moment that is what's really crippling
the whole of the Health Service in Essex
at this moment in time council emitted
high and high year I've got one question
sir Howard has a removal of the nurse's
bursary called the reduction act codes
to train as nurses and are there any of
these proposals dependent on having more
nurses
and from what I understand so far that
yes there's been a significant reduction
in the number of nursing applications I
think I had 60% is that what you've
heard yeah I think you've said number of
reductions it greatly concerns me
because every hospital in the country
has a large number of nursing vacancies
as I mentioned I also had a medical
Directorate now as well and at the
moment this is as we speak which is very
very difficult to manage and it means
that there's a lot of extra work for the
nurses that are there so retention
becomes a problem looking at the
individual modeling certainly if we look
at some downgrading to a yellow and
going along the lines of actually not
calling an A&E that coordinate walking
center and having it run by emergency
nurse practitioners you would need a
significant increase in that if you look
at the red center so going increasing
its number of patients attend there so
an example at the moment is rather than
figures I think the last ones I saw
where they have 130,000 attendances per
year looking at the success regime
figures in four years time that will be
220,000 so to manage those number of
patients yes there will be a reduction
on another site but at the moment for
example I have one majors area and that
has one of majors nurse in charge and
one majors coordinator
I couldn't double the size of my A&E and
still have one nurse in charge on one
majors coordinator so whilst the
proportion of actual nurses to the
cubicles like nurses to beds on award
would remain the same I would need a few
more chief to run the shop floor so I'd
be concerned that more are needed
and councillor eaves is next on my list
in the background I was pinions and
unlicensed accounting to me is that
means and as dr. Hammond has been our
product ask each representatives from
energetic giving of one word answer all
record as to whether you think that
critical answers in response times is
going to get worse or better by putting
the pre-hospital interface categorizing
aslan and the other hospitals so that
they've taken the emergency care of
different is it going to be better or
worse by exercising these hospitals
you mean the outcomes yes sir well
measure
you don't have the outcome fully yet of
what it is VA will always be canceled
sure my question is regarding the IP
systems for the three hospitals but
often we hear from family and friends oh
I've gone to the hospital they can't
find the button tests they can't find
this test results if you're going to
shift patients here there and everywhere
to specialist units will you have their
records - Hank that's my biggest concern
I don't know who can ask for that if
it's yourself or I don't think doctors
can thank you so that's it that's the
heat piece work we've already started
working on service sort of just to give
you an example of something that we've
done already so with radiology imaging
we have completed the process so we now
have a single what's described as a PAC
system which means that we can access
the same system across the three sides
there'd be a lot more work we need to do
in test results medical records and to
make roster three hospitals we're not
there yet but that's that's all work
would have to be done prior to a number
of these changes being able to happen I
would add that regardless of whatever
model we end up with we should be doing
that anyway because you might live near
Bath Olinda but you might work near
Southend and you might become alone
south end rather than battled and so we
need to do it anyway thank you
castor sparing and if you've been
waiting a long time Thank You chairman
well this is obviously an early part of
the consultation process and having
listened to the presentations it seemed
to me that some of the issues and
concerns that dr. Howard has expressed
have already been taken off the table
and so effectively implies that some of
the opposition views have already been
dismissed and really the the public has
had no opportunity to review these
comments improve
that that's my very pointer and that is
the reason we are both sitting here
nothing has been taken off the table and
in a way when I say it will be better I
agree entirely with with Tom we will do
nothing that isn't better therefore if
we find that red isn't better we won't
get there but none of dr. Howard's
concerned that and we discussed them
quite openly continually are off the
table which is why we're actually right
now working on the treatment transfer
model and working bit by bit because
some of dr. Howells concerns will turn
out to be real some of my my views will
turn out being correct some of the other
Howard's views which are not being
correct and some of my visual turned out
to be right of whatever but we will work
it through that that's how we function
so no it hasn't been taken off the table
and there has not been a lack of
opportunity for consolidation we haven't
actually started the official
consultation process and we've already
spoken at over a hundred events in the
last six or 12 months so if I could just
add add that so say we're doing
something quite unusual in the way that
we're undertaking this so if you look at
the sort of the slugging glorious
history of NHS consultations the way
that if you if you take London as a good
example actually all perhaps a bad
example in this what's happened is a
whole set of proposals have jumped out
at the last minute gone straight to
public consultation and it's felt very
rushed for local communities and that
people haven't been able to have their
say we aren't doing that in this case so
what we are do keeping you updated as
we're going along and as we go along and
as we listen to your views as we listen
to the view we are changing and
iterating our model and so hopefully
whatever we get to in December actually
is something that you recognize and you
understand more about
then you would have done had we followed
kind of the old way of doing public
consultations within the health service
whereby we wouldn't have said in to
think and then December would have
jumped out at us and there'd been a
whole set of proposals which we didn't
understand weren't clear about and you
wouldn't have enough time to think about
and to give your informed views too so
this is the way that we we have
deliberately decided to approach this
work to be a transplant but as a result
of being open and transparent in the way
that we have done this it does mean that
there's more uncertainty and the
position moves over time and that's a
good thing because that shows that what
we are doing is we are trying to listen
we are trying to adapt our processes we
are working to engage to resolve those
concerns and to moderate our proposals
as we go along this process to press in
terms of the way that we're doing it
which means that we can't answer every
question now but we can tell you where
we're at councillor Chris black next
thank you madam chair um one of the most
enlightening council meetings have been
to I go back to 1984 here and I can tell
the difference between the good ones and
the bad ones
I've learnt a lot tonight I'm not clear
on on a couple of things because he's
about my questions is what I'm not clear
on I'm not clear on why the good work
for mr. Stinson's doing with GPS is
linked with downgrading A&E I don't know
why were two things or even with some
document okay secondly I was very
interested hearing dr. Howard
but the preclinical leads at the
hospitals believe that we are both
against invasion orange and yellow model
and in favor of the the truce and
transfer and if I knew what the
definition of a clinical need was I'd be
even more concerned I think that perhaps
actively explained
meeting my question though actually
which is separate from most of on
tonight
it's mr. Stinson and it's not even about
directly about New Zealand South Essex
is about north ethics because you are
talking about GPS be under pressure and
difficult to attract new GPS and I've
part to do of money now I know but
somebody acquaintance of mine did a
Freedom of Information request in to to
GP practices in the north of ethics
which I believe their contract criminal
and they in one of them they were often
less money to continue and the other way
off about the same amount of money and
the contracts then went understand to
the urgent health care and my
acquaintance asked the question for
freedom a freedom the freedom of
information act as to what what was the
contract amount paid to Virgin health
care for these surgeries compared to the
previous contact and she was told but
with one one of them they were paid
about sixty percent more which astounded
me any standard her and I like the him
assistance comments about how we avoid
transferring out transferring over to
these practices in business and ethics
to expensive private companies thank you
so I won't comment up particularly on
North II settings but but the question
is around you know what is our future
vision for services and I can
categorically say Arthur and I'll have
to be here for seat sepia not CCG
because I'm not representing the other
CCGs
in the respect of general practice
specific contracting but what I am very
clear about CPR CCG is that we've got a
group of GPS here that are a good bunch
we've got a good good practices by and
large across across our locality and we
want to retain those individuals and
those practices and that ethos so we
would always look to the local community
to disperse if we were in the position
where a contract came to an end to
disperse that list amongst the local
community rather than repro cure from a
new provider of course if we are in the
position where there isn't a practice
that's able to absorb those patients we
would then go through a procurement
process but what we will be looking for
is a service that is in line with our
vision which is about a local provision
of services linked with local practices
to deliver services linking with the
acute service so I don't know if that's
going to answer your question fully
enough but but I'm very clear that from
your CCG that we will be designing our
services based around the needs of our
population and our local community of
general practices
count the moon actually work thank very
much and as a recent patient but only at
South Angel have to tell you I'm sort of
bolted to go here I thought were very
pleased with the hospital I thought they
were working to the pipsqueak everybody
was busy and I mean busy and what we're
really talking about hims we're going to
come to my question his logistics
communication IT the IT let's face it
has had real bad press isn't it last
month because it hadn't been upgraded
it's not joined up it's also about
resources now no matter how you look at
it if anybody goes saying e with a cold
and likely be admitted for an operation
so when anyone goes in the hospital I
would have thought is because they need
to go into a hospital so you've got
resources you've got numbers of baits
what I don't hear here is what we're
going to do about increasing those
resources because we're kind of
rearranging the deck chairs and the
Titanic we're moving one thing here one
thing they're moving patients around on
busy roads with growing populations and
what it really boils down to is funding
and resources and being honest about it
so when we say it's not about money if
it wasn't then we wouldn't be here
tonight so what I'm saying I'm worried
about the way this is going it looks as
if it fits in as a great deal with the
accountants but what about the personal
end of it which will unravel when the
first couple of people have a premature
death so my question is how you going to
approach trying to get more funding to
bringing all the things you need you
need the IT you need the personnel you
need all of this infrastructure that's
outside to stop people coming to
hospital unnecessarily and the modern
technologies and the things like smart
watch on your wrist cancer heart slowing
down or something I don't know but at
the end of the day how you going to go
about that argument do you think you're
going to get a sensible argument for
better better resourcing and funding out
of all
this to make it work because without it
you're going to have a problem I'm sure
I'm sure TomTom will be able to answer
more fully but there's no doubt about it
more money would be sad it will be great
if someone brought a truckload of money
down the a12 tomorrow morning we'd use
it but we would still change because it
wouldn't solve the GP problem it
wouldn't solve the nursing problem it
would install the staffing problem but
but please in your positions of power
more money would be great
so yeah just following on from that so
obviously from from an initial spective
we we get what we're given if you see
what I mean in terms of the National
Fund assessment there is an opportunity
though exactly if if we can get a good
plan together that we can all get behind
there are various little pots of money
out there held by the Department of
Health and other agencies that we can
access and so we can use that
potentially to support Ian in terms of
some of the plans that you know he needs
to take forward and work that we need to
do in terms of improving primary care
estate where there's lots of money again
where we if we can hang a good plan
together equally around the IT and some
of the other sort of key changes that we
know need to happen so what we want to
try and do is as we develop our plan
that we can all get behind is we can
then use that to leverage our
discussions with the Department of
Health and with our regulators say look
we've got some ideas about really good
changes we can make which can improve
outcomes for our local population but
we're going to need some money in order
to make those things happen that's a
much stronger argument than us just
going cap in hand and saying we just
can't make it work
so if we can get a plan together over
the course of the summer we've got a
much better chance of being able to
access some of these pots of money that
become available from from government
from time to time
okay cancel it now cast out him next
please so my question really was mainly
about funding and I think most of us
agree that the NHS is severely
underfunded how these changes these
proposed changes being costed and how
will they be funded are we are we going
to hopefully obtain extra funding for
from the government to cover this these
quite serious changes that are being
proposed so so kind of my previous
answer sort of slightly refer to that in
terms of trying to access sort of the
additional funding from the 12 health
fund any changes what we are doing
because as you've seen our proposals and
thinking of is changing we are costing
it as we go along to understand what the
financial impact will be on the three
hospitals and on the NHS more broadly
clearly if our plans for community
services pay off which means that there
are less kind less people needing to be
admitted to hospitals Ian's already
outlined that's great because not only
is that good for the person who doesn't
need to go into the hospital but equally
it's a hospital bed that potentially we
don't need to use in the future so we
are costing it obviously within any
final proposal that we come back with
that will be fully costed and so we can
then demonstrate what impact that would
have and how any change would be funded
over the implementation period of that
change
I've got councilors Webb Griffin and
Kassar to speak neck to ask their
questions next there's anybody who's not
who hasn't asked a question yet and they
want to can you put your hands up before
I go back to people that have already
asked a question so the next one is
councillor Webb thank you just got a
couple of questions if I may
my first one is really who is
championing Southend hospital is
excellent to see dr. Howard here this
evening but no she's not normally
present at these meetings and certainly
when I attended last night there was no
clinical representation there so it
asked first well who is actually
standing up to South Plains interest
within this process I'd like to ask a
bit more about yes TP boarding former as
well
could you clarify your roles in
governance please who makes the
decisions and how and to what extent is
it possible for the decisions of an STP
to override those of a consultant body
I'd also like to ask a question about
Basildon if I may
I agree things I mean in some cases
neatly centralized however we've just
heard the president if it becomes the
same the irate I&E would potentially
have an extra two hundred and twenty
thousand patients going into it how will
battling cope when those patients don't
just going to A&E but a dissipated
throughout the entire hospital system as
my wife works in a hospital I know how
difficult it can be when a patient goes
by any they don't just explained there
that I referred all other parts of the
hospital my question there is how about
it is hope with these extra numbers I'd
appreciate your on thank you
yes Thank You councillor webbing that
there were two questions there and I
haven't been trying to restrict
everybody to one question or inference
or yes I know everybody is waiting but
we're nearly at the end of the list so
I'll let you get away with that one okay
so I'll try try to get to those so in
terms to who's standing up for Basildon
so we'll know who's standing up for
South End and we're all standing up the
South End I am legally responsible as an
effects director South End Hospital and
I am countable to you and to the
population of South End and cost point
and Rockford to make sure that South End
delivers safe effect
of services day-in day-out we know that
we can't consistently do that all the
time now so we do need to change I'm
sure Ian and other colleagues would say
exactly the same thing in terms of the
STP Board the STP board is made up of
chief executives from the CCGs and key
NHS provider organizations at the moment
they will make recommendations they do
not make any decisions a decision around
any consultation and any service change
will be made by the clinical
commissioning groups across mid and
South Essex they have the legal
responsibility and the legal duty to do
that so they are the people who will do
that and then in terms of the Basildon
so it would be an increase I think of
from one hundred and thirty thousand to
two hundred and twenty thousand would be
I think is what we describes clearly if
we were to do that they would need to be
a number of a number of significant
changes to set those thousands and A&E
departments so that would it would need
to be expanded we'd need to recruit so
within any proposals that we need we
were bring forward we would articulate
these are the changes that would be made
to any of the three departments to
manage the changes that we would be
consulting on from a clinical
perspective councillor Griffin
thank you all for coming this evening
it's been very informative
two simple questions the area that the
hospitals cover how far to the west and
the north it is your responsibility and
West I mean we we interviewed you did
with Harlow that's you you you probably
know the actual back okay so West is
broadly over to the m25 boundary and and
up to Harlow and and then north we sort
of kind of cut off around us further
around that sort of part of the world
and it sort of the furthest north that
our hatch covers now they are making
changes and and all STDs and they're 42
of them in the country are making
changes many of them the proposed
changes are similar to our proposed
changes but actually you bring up a
really important point that it's
actually why we focus on our one point
to a million and that for the the actual
borders and there are patients that that
will move that way and into us from
there so we have to be talking to them
as well and we are this is contact stuff
yeah counselor Kassar
okay thank you sure and we have listened
to you for a long time and it's been
extremely interesting I still don't
understand how the change in the a into
the business hospitals a gross elective
system more efficient and most
importantly more effective the changes
to the entire system and I know that
might be frustrating to hear that but it
is not just the a any changes that make
the system more effective and and more
efficient and better for outcome if we
just change their knees it wouldn't work
actually you've heard very clearly that
probably the majority of change is
required in the out of hospital portion
and so it truly is an entire system
change to create a new way of delivering
health in this area you're right the
only changes any of them are at any
level within those that we have spoken
about whichever level we go to will not
on their own deliver the change this is
an entire system process otherwise it
won't work and that what makes it so
difficult and so complex and that's why
you know at times we appear we're really
here to tell you this is where we are
I don't disagree with you but there are
some caveats to that so going back to
what I said the first time the eighties
I don't believe are broken it's about
that big for our priority medical group
and I think so much of this does sit in
the pre-hospital community situation to
get resolution there I believe without
that everything that we are planning and
that's not just a a that's also the
specialty pathways anesthetics ITU
Vascular everything without solving that
then this will all fail because as I've
stated there is not enough medical base
in the system as it is at this moment in
time it doesn't matter where you put
them and how you divide them out when
there isn't enough they will be spill
over into elective care beds and we will
run into the same problem I'd say there
are situations where we do have to admit
patients that don't have an acute
medical need because there is no other
safe alternative that unfortunately does
still happen it's a little reflection of
not all services running 24/7 365 days a
year
so there is improvements that can be be
had there and I still am in the
situation you know 10 o'clock at night
in the A&E that I've got an elderly
patient who's got no acute medical
problem but nowhere else to go so there
are there are little gains here and
there but overall it's that big
population group which is which is
causing the problem and unfortunately
it's that group that she's going to grow
as well
councillor Weston
Thank You chairman
my question is you will sit round the
table have all these consultations with
doctors clinicals whoever what if you
can't make a decision that you all agree
on are you just going to just override
it and just go ahead thank you
so we'll have to make a call if we get
to that point I hope we don't so if if
we get that point then we will have to
lay out this is this is what we think is
the best way forward for our system
these are the pros and these the cons
about it as you you know we're not you
know that we will go out with that and
say on balance this is what we think the
best thing in turn to the reform of
health services are and then we'll have
to see the feedback from local
communities about those proposals and
that is the purpose of the kind of the
formal consultation and then ultimately
it will be a decision which is made by
our clinical commissioning groups in
terms of what is that the way they want
to proceed so I would add just to define
the clinical leads question so when I
use that term it basically the clinical
lead or clinical director easily Dean
Sultan in the A&E so after any you'll
have six to ten consultants it's a boss
consultant effectively that has been you
know interviewed and promoted to that
position today and it affects
representing their department
I would hope it wouldn't come to that
because you have the free bas
consultants of the free ane departments
are involved singing from the same hymn
sheet
I think everybody's had an opportunity
to speak so I will return to counselor
Gooding broad and cut more who would
like to have a second question
[Music]
Thank You chair from from what I've been
hearing this evening it seems like
before we even think about going to the
hospital side of things and changing all
this system to red amber and yellow it
would seem that it's far more important
to work on the primary care and getting
all this in place before we even go in
near this and this should be put back at
least a couple of years before this
system is in place for what in citizen
is they're proposing so it is a rat age
it's a good point but I do think this is
where the two systems have to work as
one system so we've got to work in
tandem on this and it's about taking the
steps together and delivering what we
need to deliver out of hospital the
challenge for me always is from my
colleagues it's how fast you can go and
that's the challenge that we've now got
to take forward how fast can we go in
terms about Hospital to enable you know
the system to work effectively so we've
heard from Caroline dr. Howard talking
about you know the frustrations that she
has in terms of not not having the
system around her working effectively
and we've got to find ways of doing of
doing that speedily but it's a
complicated a complicated system and we
have what we have to get it right
thank you very much chairman for coming
for allowing me to come back
I think medicines obviously made
enormous strides over the last four or
five decades so the fact that we are now
actually the victims of our own success
in as much as that we're keeping people
alive probably far in excess at the time
that they would have been alive for and
we've got a major problem on our hands
in regards to that but one of the things
that I notice from times gone by was
convalescence and recovery care which
seems to be non-existent from what I can
see and understand surely this should be
something that could be taken into
consideration as you go forward because
one of the things that I think is really
necessary within Hospital if people have
move on is to have really specialized
convalescence and recovery and good
catering because that all goes together
with reeling the patient quicker and
that seems to be very absent in the
rural hospitals definitely the catering
side and you know this is something that
really does need to be looked at to have
that separated out where you don't need
to have the clinicians there it's
lawless
a case of building people up and getting
them out and moving them on to somewhere
else so maybe that's something you can
look to to the future so it would
actually alleviate this bed blocking
problem that we keep on coming back to
thank you Jim again as a clinician I
would agree with you and I think this is
that's part that got me past the
community plan and I Lou did to earlier
the problem that we have of discharging
people and then a significant percentage
are coming back in in a very short
timeframe as well and I totally agree
that it needs to be addressed as well
councillor Cutler Thank You Jim medow
chairman just say I know from personal
experience kind of months ago that the
actual food that Southie investment was
very good now fortunately and I had a
guess trying to internal bleed that you
were talking about earlier so I couldn't
solve any of it but what I saw was very
good but I need to make a declaration
chairman because I'm also a member of
West Essex Clinical Commissioning group
and I know that us was good was
mentioned so I represent ethics on that
particular power so I need to mention
that as an interest but just to say to
all of the people that are here I think
we've had a really good discussion
tonight I think that an awful more but I
think there's a lot still a lot to learn
and I think there's still a long way to
go now what I want from you if I may is
we've convened this meeting here I'm
sure there are other people you're going
to have to go to and there will be
consultation out there to actually meet
other groups etc talk it through I'm
sure I'll see in in my role as chairman
of the local health and well-being board
class appoint Rochford but all I'm
saying is is there a mechanism by which
you can keep us up to date so that we
know what if you like the sort of pulse
of what's going on and any problems you
might have or any opinions who might
seek from the public going forward now I
don't want to take up a lot of your time
on this but once just wondered if you've
you thought of a mechanism that we could
take these folks I think it's an
important part of the equation for the
public because we represent the public
in this matter
Thank You chairman
you you're uptight we can't communicate
enough and communication is vital and we
are committed to that and we do have a
communications strategy and
communications lead we do have a website
we do go out to the public and we would
like to do more and more of it because
uncomfortable though it is at times it's
absolutely vital because a we get
information and it informs our thoughts
and we would like to do much more better
and we will continue to do this and
should you wish us to come back we would
be very happy to do so I can select on
from trans come talk more yes I must
communicate please come back I think you
go by tonight with views of members here
and I'm making the assumption here but I
think about half of us are doubtful
about the orange red yellow model and
the other half of us are dead against it
I'm not seeing anybody X's you know but
just to go back to mr. Abel
you said although you are you are
accountable yeah could you clarify in
what way I mean I mean I'm accountable
we are all accountable to our residents
we get things wrong they can buy us out
your little category elected but in what
way are you accountable and who you
accountable to
okay and so as an executive director of
an NHS trust managers Foundation Trust
of which I am I am accountable to the
board and I am accountable to the
governors of the foundation trust the
governors of foundation trust are
elected by the membership which are
members of the local community so that
that is my ultimate accountability
through 2/3 to the governor's I also
have an accountability through to the
Secretary of State as well and the last
question
councillor hook why thank you madam
chairman follow me to come back and I'd
like to thank everyone who attended this
evening it's been very informative and I
would imagine that for most people in
relation to the changes that being
looked at and the the biggest concerns
are in those very few an occasional
situations where it's a life-and-death
situation and I mean the the concern is
is that they'll be treated in the most
appropriate efficient way possible to
have the best outcome and now another
thing that's interested that's come up
this evening means is in relation to
discussions of how the clinical and the
hospital side of things deals with the
social care side of looking after people
now it would seem that in some some
respects this has been talked of as if
it was something new but this has been a
discussion that I sure I'm sure that
many of you know goes back decades and
it's been discussed on numerous
occasions of how to bring these two
together so that there's a seamless
change from one to another now for for
us you know the situation with how we
deal and meet with you as professionals
in your field is very much Anna
on a personal basis when when situations
arise and mention it's made before about
illnesses such as COPD and my father
suffered with COPD for many years and
and unfortunately last year he ended up
in the hospital and it seemed that he
from our perspective
he was released too soon and and the
facilities were not there for him to be
dealt with when he went back home and
unfortunately fairly shortly afterwards
he passed away now from my perspective
and my family's perspective we're never
going to be completely sure that the you
know he was released too soon because
there was a need for that bid for
someone else and that will always be
with me and as to a wonder as to why he
was released into back into the
community where he was not properly
provided for thank you
I'm really sorry to hear about your
father and my condolences there at the
clinician and I'm sure Caroline would
agree and certainly I know from my
experiences in one hospital man and I
have no doubt it goes well three people
are not consciously sent home unless it
is felt it is appropriate to do so but
and I think please take some reassurance
from that and that is a clinical
decision but you do touch on a point
that has been made by us all and that is
the ability to convalesce appropriately
the ability to provide social care
outside of the hospital is an issue as
well as all the other issues that we
have to deal with and it has to be part
of this system improvement that we're
making a society or your story and the
final final I'm sorry I was described by
condoning PC but also say that that
convalescence party is really as you say
it's not a new problem this this has
been happening every winter I've now
been in A&E for 15 years which makes me
feel very old but this is a problem
that's been getting worse and worse over
those 15 years when we do see the big
respiratory problems and people coming
back not long after they've been
discharged from hospital I think we have
to be very careful as well of what we're
doing in the community to make sure that
actually has an effect because having
worked 15 years in a knee I've probably
seen 15 years of winter pressure plans
which really haven't seem to make any
difference to someone working in A&E as
well there's very limited evidence out
there for what happens in the community
to prevent people coming in and what
kind of care they actually need so we
need to make sure that's done correctly
as well so the final final questions
cancer hi mister hi
thank you for letting me in there thank
you very much for coming tonight I think
they explained quite nicely as other
councillors say I did hear a
presentation at the reviewed with you I
think about years ago and I can say that
things have definitely changed from that
presentation to this presentation so
good to know that you do listen the
question is have any of you met with
save yourself in and hear their concerns
so actually I met with some of them
yesterday because I was of the westboro
Community Association and one of our
challenges has been that because we've
been in a slightly extended perda period
our ability to engage externally and and
it has been limited I know one of the
things that we talk to them about
yesterday was around us starting to
develop a dialogue with and with save
and so so we can get get get a
conversation going between kind of the
people who are doing some of this work
and and that group so I hope that we can
kind of build on this conversation that
we started yesterday well thank you
everybody I think we've had a very good
discussion tonight everybody has had the
opportunity to ask questions thank you
to everybody for coming along and the
presentation I will remind everyone as
members of the public and that includes
councillors there is going to be
consultation starting in December yes
and it is moving so I would urge all the
members of the public sitting in the
back to ensure that you take part in
this consultation and also the council
members as well but thank you very much
for tonight thank you
we all please be upstanding while the
Chairman and the managing director leave
the chain
um thank you very much